là aux portes de la ville
c'est un peu la rivière des sans-souci
l'image même d'une france paisible et
presque chanceuse enfin c'est ce que
croit ceux qui ne vivent pas car non
loin de ce cours d'eau
il y à d'autres lieux encore plus
paisible et qui visiblement ont un
problème avec le 21e siècle
pour découvrir la france des petites
villes en 2018
il vaut mieux avoir le permis et garder
un oeil sur le compteur allure la cité
du sapeur camember comme à
luxeuil-les-bains réputé pour ces termes
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ceux
qui se retroussent les manches pour que
lors de ville retrouve des couleurs
c'est le cas de stéphane le boulanger
les commerces désertent les
centres-villes et bien lui il a décidé
de s'y installer
tout n'a voulu me dissuader même c'est
eux
je pense qu à part moi mon banquier j'ai
mon avis personne n'y croyait à cette
histoire donc donc bon c'était le
principal
il ya quand même des choses qui bougent
c'est vrai que l'udc se sont ils étaient
tombés très bas
il suffit de se promener dans la rue
principale pour voir les les vitrines à
vendre donc mais non ça oui y'a pas de
raison ça a l'air de vouloir dynamiser
un petit peu il ya des gens qui ont
l'air de d'avoir envie que ça bouge quoi
donc on verra
s'intéresser à l'urée à luxeuil n'est
pas vraiment un hasard
ces deux petites agglomérations de
haute-saône presque voisine font
régulièrement l'actualité en raison des
difficultés qu'elles rencontrent et des
services publics qu'elle voit partir il
tant qu'on ramasse des coups derrière
les oreilles mais on se dit à quoi bon à
quoi bon mais c'est toujours bon jour
bon de montrer les dents puis de montrer
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas une réserve
d'indiens ici quoi faut faut arrêter
pour ces militants syndicaux la
situation pourrait même empirer avec
l'actuel gouvernement
là on va saint sauveur le petit village
qui est juste à côté là au bout de la
ligne droite qui colle à luxeuil où il y
avait un
il y avait un bureau de poste entre
guillemets de plein exercice où il y
avait des gens qui travaillaient où il y
avait une zone d'instance des postiers
qui ne se lasse jamais de vous montrer
les conséquences de ce management de la
fermeture faut pas oublier que le
citoyen y les contribuables il est les
deux en retour s'ils participent à la
collecte fiscale c'est qu'en retour il
est censé avoir je sais pas une école
pas trop loin un service un service de
santé pas trop loin une gendarmerie
présente pas trop loin puis au moins à
merde son bureau de poste pas trop loin
mais certains ont décidé de ne pas se
laisser faire
michel antony est à la tête d'un comité
de vigilance pour le maintien des
services publics allure par exemple
l'état a décidé de fermer la prison
jugés trop vétustes
la population s'est alors mobilisée et
le gouvernement à premier la
construction d'une nouvelle maison
d'arrêt services publics maison d'arrêt
c'est un service public aussi quoi c'est
pas de l'udc ont préféré conserver vous
préférez des trains en permanence on
peut faire des écoles plus nombreuses
vous préférez des urgences bien ce mur
mais bon ou maison d'arrêt ça fait aussi
partie de notre quotidien c'est du
boulot c'est les gens qui travaillent
c'est des gens qui font un temps de
peine qui ont droit aussi être proche
d'eux
leurs amis leurs paroles leurs copains
pour cet historien spécialiste des
huttes au pied de l'autogestion ce qui
ne donne pas de la voix ne sauveront
rien de leur territoire pour lui ces
mêmes aujourd'hui un choix de société
même les élus les plus favorables à la
reconversion
deux territoires à la concentration la
métropolisation ils se rendent compte
que leur territoire disparaît que leur
petite cité disparaître et quand on
faire des petites localités ici qu'est
ce qui se passe dans les gens sur les
grandes et grandes qui sont saturés
on ferme une urgence ici on a des
urgences capturé à besançon puis à dijon
donc ces imbéciles cd
position qui sont qui sont en dehors de
tout bon sens les élus de terrain
justement qui doivent souvent faire plus
avec moins
sont ils toujours gagné par la déprime
ou contraire va-t-il enfin l' avenir
s'éclaircir à luxeuil
on préfère s'appuyer sur le dynamisme
retrouvé de cette petite zone
industrielle pour combattre une idée
reçue celle du sauve-qui-peut là
typiquement une entreprise là mais neil
qui est là depuis le début
qui a cru au territoire et qu'ils
rentrent maintenant de construire ce
bâtiment juste à côté
si ça ne va pas très fort du côté des
emplois publics
ça n'empêche pas la reprise des
investissements privés
on commence à avoir les avantages de nos
inconvénient c'est à dire que on a des
bâtiments disponibles
on a une offre immobilière accessible et
aujourd'hui on pourrait imaginer une
politique audacieuse au niveau de l'état
consistant à réinvestir sur le monde
rural
parce qu'il n'ya pas le problème de
stationnement comme il ya dans les
grands pôles urbains ya pas le problème
du prix de l'immobilier y a pas tout ça
je suis très optimiste dans cette région
située au pied des vosges il y ait enfin
une activité économique qui demeure à un
bon baromètre du business local la syrie
gionet existe depuis des décennies
ce n'est pas la fermeture d'un bureau de
poste qui peut faire trébucher le si
leur nom ce sont plutôt les règles du
marché
on a une des premières forêts d'europe
mais notre balance notre balance
commerciale sur les produits forestiers
elle est négative on exporte plus de
produits et puis on va ré importé du
meuble la belgique l'italie
nous exportons du meuble ça on pourrait
savoir faire en france et il ya encore
des fabricants qu'ils savent faire parce
qu'ils sont modernisés un patron qui ne
s'inquiète pas trop pour l'avenir car
ici plus qu'ailleurs on peut compter sur
des salariés attachés à leur territoire
vous avez le père qui travaille ici qui
fait rentrer son fils son neveu
je suis vraiment un tissu de gens très
sérieux et je suis entouré de tout 1 2
de nombreuses entreprises sous
traitantes qui me permettent de me
dépanner en mécanique en électricité et
ce sont des gens très compétents
donc moi je vois pas pourquoi on
pourrait pas continuer à se développer
ici
dans cette france de l'est à l'écart des
métropoles régionales
on hésite encore à miser sur des matins
ensoleillés
un an après l'arrivée d' emmanuel macron
certains évoquent une atmosphère
positive mais d'autres des combats à
venir contre la vitesse à 80 km heure
par exemple
une mesure qui symbolise elle aussi la
fracture territoriale